much of the country faces a blast of
bitterly cold weather this morning along
with a series of snowstorms
threatening the east and midwest an icy
mass of air will dive down from western
canada
reaching as far south as texas by this
weekend
cbs news meteorologist and climate
specialist jeff berardelli joins us jeff
good morning
good morning anthony good morning
everybody the polar vortex is going to
pay us a visit
and it is not going to be a very
pleasant guest unfortunately bringing
with it
the coldest air in the world right now
down canada and all the way down to
texas
we have a big blocking warm high across
the arctic that is displacing
and forcing an arctic invasion across
the nation's heartland and boy
is it going to get cold especially as we
head into sunday morning it's already
cold
but this will be the coldest morning
look at that 51 below
the wind chill in fargo 48 below in
rockford illinois
about 13 below in oklahoma city and in
kansas city 16 below
and you know during the day in kansas
city and st
louis it's going to be colder there than
it will be in fairbanks alaska
now along this boundary very cold and
very warm air
lots of alerts going up because there's
going to be you know a conveyor belt of
storm
after storm kind of an assembly line of
storm after storm and it's going to be
ice
right along the boundary and then snow
to the north so in places like dallas
and little rock and paducah it is ice
but east of that in places like
washington dc
and west virginia it's snow and it will
pile up
but it will not really get to boston and
it'll barely get to new york and that's
because
it's going to run into a wall of cold
and dry air it's never
too cold to snow but sometimes it can
suppress systems to the south
there is the icy accumulation to the
south and places like d.c
three to six inches of snow some places
in virginia and west virginia
may be as much as 10 inches and tony if
that's not enough fun for you
we have at least two to three more
storms in the pipeline
the takeaway from me jeffy is it could
be the coldest valentine's day on record
so gentlemen
get the flowers before sunday morning
you are not going to want to bundle up
and go out
all right jeff thank you very much